this this picture will give us our
definition so I'd like you to only
histogram it can give me a sentence that
says an angle yes all I'm really doing
is we're measuring the size of this
thing right the size of this it's
different to getting a ruler out and
measuring how long something is or
having an area of something like that an
angle is a way to measure these are
keyway the size and what I'm looking at
here as well how would you describe like
from this arm up here to this arm down
here what happens to this arm to get to
this one like what kind of movement is
it doing how did you describe it yeah
it's kind of like you're sort of taking
it and rotating it this way right or a
most simple way would be your attorney
would punch you so and it goes a way to
Ray to the size of a rotation or eternal
that's all angles are about right and
that's why a was everywhere because
rotations and turn by everywhere all
those ways okay so now we know how to
talk about angles is well that last
piece that I want to talk about a little
sort of descriptive word which will help
us if you do another one of these you
can draw it a maybe a bit smaller
underneath but I wanted to have more
than one egg one so draw something like
this
okay so here I have who I have actually
eggless do I have in this diagram how
many English do you count middle awake
count isn't it right sir in which was
you sir okay so I could say like I've
got angle I'm gonna give it a name
a B C I'm gonna market with someone
named for me another one yeah someone
named another angle
yes okay now it might be your body well
I should say they're the size of this
I'm just interested in naming it like as
in what what is the what's it called as
opposed to how big is so for example
this one is a big see I can see I also
have C B did you see that one okay put
that agree so I've got angle a
and I've got angle C be deep before
21:38 we lose someone or something one
bit but they don't to point out about
these two is that do you notice that
they share and see that the chef BC is
an arm of the second that's an above
that age does that make sense so
therefore since these ankles share and
on because these Abel's sharing are we
called them adjacent angles they next to
each other right
they got yes now does anyone see what is
the third angle it's kind of a bit
stinky okay now there is this is
actually I was thinking about anyway
you've got an angle that goes all the
way around here
okay that's especially we will get to
that in your time I won't clog up a
diagram with it very this I guess that
means there's a poor thing yeah abd abd
yes it kind of includes both of those
together right so this angle abd right
so either there's this three and I'll
talk about that other one the dotted one
I'll talk about that anyone else with us
this time we love when we catch it okay
so what do we come so far we've got all
these pieces that go into a an angle we
know how to talk about English describe
the mainland and we also know what it
even is adjacent one last thing I was
saying down here I said some people call
this eight right and I said can at least
you'll know what it means but I don't
really like doing them see what
it's the Rococo based on this diagram
you want to see why that kind of way of
doing things
causes issues yeah yeah we just went to
the point of saying look there's all
these different angles on the same
diagram and three is the vertex for all
right so you say babe babe which boob do
you need is a pocket veto or and it's
very ambiguous right so therefore but
you actually can't say because you no
one knows which one you're talking about
okay so that's why in this case you need
to use these and these are always been
up there's never a shadow of a doubt
they don't have video so okay yes okay
all right don't break this down so put
your pins out of your hand through
second I will tell it to you cuz I'm
curious and it's this angle here is
called a reflex angle
we're gonna meet reflex eight moves in a
future lesson which is why I want you to
cloud this diagram with that cuz we're
gonna talk about at the right time but
that's what it's referring to when you
say a go around the back a really big
angle like that that's the special name
but we will meet those and otherwise
okay